[Music]
you
holy crap everybody what the heck was
that we just got the end of season 2 now
the drop in season 3 stuff is basically
a bunch of preview pages for what
they're going to be doing next so I'll
explain what's going on just like the
footage says the episodes will be
dropping next year so be sure to
subscribe to get everything if you're
new to the channel this is it it's going
to be way more episodes though because
they'll be doing the uprising arc and a
lot to cover way more material than they
cover during this condense run so it
sounds like they've already been in
production for awhile or they had plans
going into season 2 how they were going
to handle season 3 which I think was
great I love the way they ended that
especially with the reveal of Aaron in
the founding Titan so if you don't know
what that is I'll explain in a minute
it's a bit of a history lesson but if
you want to read the next arc in the
manga it starts with chapter 51 and goes
all the way through 70s so that's a lot
of material that's why they're saying
it's going to be double the episode
count but it just builds on the big
reveals of this arc so you learn that
these Titans used to be the people of
connie's village you learn who historia
really is you learn about her bloodline
you learn about the origins of the
Titans you start learning about the
Titan Wars and why it is that people
went to parodies how the walls were
built is sort of pulling the wool back
from the big WTF season one where you're
like oh my god there are these Titans
attacking people it's almost like The
Walking Dead with Giants and then slowly
it turns into more of a fantasy game of
thrones story that goes back thousands
and thousands of years so if you watch
the animations at the beginning and at
the end of episodes that basically tells
the entire history of the world so if
you look at them really closely you can
see how they tell the story of how the
original queen of aldia found this
organic material used it to create the
founding Titan then use that to dominate
Elvia and they would pass it through the
royal bloodline so you could create
other Titans and you could control them
using this but only people in their
family about 1700 years after that the
king at the time grew tired of fighting
all these Titan Wars so he left to
create parodies use the Titans to create
the walls that's why they're Titans in
the walls because they help build them
they're also a security measure too but
when he left with the founding Titan
things only
were so it raised the world and you
learn about the other powers that the
founding Titan has most notably memory
control so that's how he could make
everybody forget how the walls were
built in what the history of the world
was so the Titan wars that you think
have been only going on for the last
hundred years or so had actually been
going on for thousands of years so the
next big arc is all about Aaron historia
in their group deciding what to do with
that information in how they're going to
overthrow the corrupt government the
great titan war was something fought
with a nation called Majerle they're
basically like the Nazi Germany of the
series
so they take possession of a bunch of
the original Titans and it turns the
tide of the battle so that's where the
walls come in really handy so in
addition to restoring historia to the
throne of parodies Aaron also has to
deal with all these external forces -
that start to manifest later in the
story the reason that Aaron is able to
control the bounding Titan even though
it doesn't seem like he's part of the
royal family like historia is is because
he comes into physical contact with Dyna
Fritz's Titan form and she's the first
wife of Aaron's father who also had
another son that I'll explain at the end
of the video because he was like that
last big reveal so I'll explain who Zeke
is in a second so you have historia and
Aaron they could both control the
founding Titan so you'll see that play
out let me know what you thought of
season 2 so far I feel like they've
gotten to all the really cool reveals
now like you've seen some cool [ __ ] now
we're going to tell you what it means
and then subvert your expectations by
showing you that none of that really
matters because there's so much bigger
stuff that's happening you're part of
something that's so much grander in so
much older you're left shattered by home
sacrifice trying to avenge Aaron's
mother but unable to do so you know you
can think about is Aaron activating the
founding Titan definitely one of the
best moments of the finale like they
want to leave you on a high moment even
though it's really WTF because you're
watching people you care about just get
ripped to shreds and eaten by the other
Titans and then we got to talk about
near flippin sides saying that
everything she's done has been for the
benefit of historia she's been one of
the most interesting characters this
season it's going to be fun to see air
and get really pissed off about her his
store
it cares about her recognises what's
going on but everybody else does not
everybody else hates the [ __ ] out of her
but there's so much going on with the
Warriors of Marley Bryner Bertold mere
historia it's going to get way crazier
before it slows down so if you need to
catch up then now's a good time to go
back and re-watch the episodes or reread
the manga whichever you want to do La
Jolla
[Music]
so the big teaser at the end when he
says not yet
that's Zeke Jager he's Aaron's half
brother from a different mother the one
that Aaron's struck that enabled him to
control the founding Titan now he also
has the coordinate so that's the other
part of the equation
in that is what Zeke is after so when he
says not yet he's also in control of
Bertolt and Reiner so he sort of like
the big boss behind those two crazies
that you've seen all season long this
year so you get a little tease for the
B's Titan then he comes back at the end
like oh I'm coming for you I'm coming
for you in a little while
very nice antagonistic but if it wasn't
clear he's part of the forces of Marley
so now it's more Marley versus parodies
that's become more clear it's less
Titans versus parodies and it's more
about that other external force
basically the Nazis of the series versus
our heroes but if you have any special
requests for bonus videos leave them in
the comments below there's going to be
new Game of Thrones coming next I'll try
to post that as quick as possible thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
you
[Music]